[Música]
Ucrania rechazó la propuesta del alto al
fuego de 36 horas hecha por el
presidente ruso Vladimir Putin tras un
pedido Expreso hecho por el patriarca de
la iglesia ortodoxa rusa kiev exigió que
las tropas de Rusia abandonen el
territorio ucraniano para poder
Establecer un alto el fuego
fuente desde el gobierno mexicano
confirmaron la captura de Ovidio Guzmán
hijo del narcotraficante Joaquín El
Chapo Guzmán en un operativo en el
Estado de Sinaloa Guzmán fue detenido en
2019 sin embargo el presidente mexicano
Andrés Manuel López Obrador ordenó
liberarlo para evitar un brote de
violencia en el país
y los restos del Papa Benedicto 16 ya
descansan en las grutas del Vaticano
después de que varios días de cámara
ardiente fueran allí llevados a cabo
para que cientos de miles de personas
fueran a despedir al que fuera el sumo
pontífice el Papa Francisco presidió el
funeral en el que sacerdote si el
público en general le dio el último
adiós al papa retirado
Muy buenas tardes Bienvenidos a las
noticias de France 24 soy Santiago López
González Gracias por estar con nosotros
hasta ahora Ucrania rechazó la propuesta
de ciencia al fuego por espacios de 36
horas presentada por el presidente de
Rusia Vladimir Putin quien ofreció La
tregua con motivo de la Navidad ortodoxa
que es celebrada el 7 de enero el
gobierno del presidente ucraniano
argumentó que la única forma para que
haya un cese al fuego es por medio del
retiro de las tropas rusas de las zonas
ocupadas en Ucrania la decisión Del
kremlin de proponer esta tregua tuvo
lugar después de que el patriarca quiril
que es el máximo líder de la iglesia
ortodoxa rusa pidiera una tregua con
motivo de la Navidad vamos a analizar
esta noticia está con nosotros Vladimir
rubinsky él es el profesor de ciencia
política y relaciones internacionales de
la universidad y Ceci los saludamos en
la Ciudad de Cali en el suroccidente de
Colombia Señor rubinsky gracias por
estar con nosotros y cómo interpreta
usted este ofrecimiento por parte del
presidente como un gesto de buena
voluntad o como una forma de ganar
tiempo también en la batalla además es
una propuesta que viene sugerida por la
iglesia ortodoxa rusa que precisamente
ha avalado la invasión y la muerte de
ucranianos
Muchas gracias por la orientación en
primer lugar y yo creo que lo que estaba
buscando Vladimir Putin es demostrar el
valor que tiene la religión para su
discurso su gran narrativa que Ucrania y
Rusia y los ucranianos son los rusos es
un solo pueblo porque la probabilidad
del rechazo por parte de los ucranianos
de esta propuesta era muy alta hay que
tener en cuenta que 80 por ciento de los
ucranianos manifiestan que son ortodoxos
y la pelea de las narrativas Ha sido
también muy fuerte en el campo de la
iglesia la iglesia ortodoxa en el mayo
de este año declaró su completa
independencia del patriarcado de
moscovia y precisamente el pedido del
patriarco querido que se conoce que es
muy cercano Vladimir Putin buscaba
tratar de mandar al mensaje que la
Navidad es una ocasión más para poder
decir que ucranianos rusos son parte del
mismo pueblo eso precisamente porque fue
rechazado por Ucrania señor rubis que
hablemos de la respuesta por parte de
Ucrania un rechazo total a esta
propuesta y piden el retiro de las
tropas rusas de las zonas ocupadas esto
Qué impacto puede tener en el conflicto
en el plazo inmediato y en el mediano
plazo
bueno nosotros tenemos una situación
bastante
interesante y si uno puede hablar en
estos términos sobre una guerra que
cuesta vidas de miles de personas ya
porque ambas partes están hablando sobre
la paz sobre la necesidad de una tregua
sobre la necesidad de terminar con el
combate pero cada uno por lo menos hasta
ahora está poniendo las condiciones que
a priori sabe que no va a ser aceptados
Por otra parte y en este caso la
propuesta de Putin era destinada para
ser rechazada por los ucranianos porque
cada una de las partes está mirando los
combates de manera diaria como una
oportunidad o avanzar o no dejar que
otros avancen señor rubinski muy puntual
por favor Cómo interpreta usted también
ese pedido que también ya había hecho
previamente el presidente Turco para
este es el fuego Qué necesidad tiene
erdogan de entrar en esta ecuación Y qué
necesidad tiene Turquía de ser partícipe
de esta posible
tregua entre las partes
en un principio Turquía es un candidato
muy bueno para ser mediador en este
conflicto porque goza de confianza tanto
de Rusia como de Ucrania sin embargo
simplemente la voluntad de erdogan
actuar así no es suficiente necesitamos
también por la voluntad tanto de Rusia
como Ucrania señor rubinsky muchas
gracias por estar con nosotros en France
24 es pasiva díacoyú vamos a cambiar de
tema Fuentes del gobierno mexicano
confirmaron de manera extraoficial la
captura en un operativo en el Estado de
Sinaloa de Ovidio Guzmán hijo del
narcotraficante Joaquín El Chapo Guzmán
Guzmán ya había sido detenido en 2019
sin embargo el presidente mexicano
Andrés Manuel López Obrador ordenó
liberarlo para evitar un brote de
violencia en el país Mario carbonel
corresponsal de France 24 en México nos
da más detalles escuchemos
Desde la madrugada de este jueves inició
un fuerte operativo de fuerzas federales
comandadas por el ejército mexicano y la
fuerza aérea en el Estado de Sinaloa
concretamente en la capital en Culiacán
operativo que ha dado como resultado de
acuerdo con Fuentes federales la captura
de Ovidio Guzmán hijo de Joaquín El
Chapo Guzmán este sujeto apodado el
ratón hay que recordar ya había sido
capturado en octubre de 2019 pero tuvo
que ser liberado en aquella ocasión por
el riesgo que corría la población dada
la represalias de este grupo criminal en
esta ocasión en la fuerza aérea utilizó
Incluso un helicóptero artillado que
disparó metralleta en este operativo
para capturar a Ovidio que es
considerado junto con sus hermanos el
líder del Cartel De Sinaloa y este
operativo hay que señalarlo se da a sólo
unos días de que llega a México Joe
biden presidente de los Estados Unidos
país que reclama en extradición a Ovidio
por enfrentar distintos cargos
relacionados con el narcotráfico desde
el inicio de este operativo se han
desatado balaceras y bloqueos por parte
del crimen organizado que ha atravesado
camiones y los ha incendiado en
distintos accesos a la ciudad Asimismo
el aeropuerto ha sido cerrado a las
operaciones las líneas aéreas
comerciales han suspendido los vuelos y
el gobernador del estado Rubén Rocha ha
llamado a la población a mantenerse a
salvo a mantenerse en casa a no salir a
las calles las clases han sido
suspendidas las labores en las oficinas
de gobierno también se cancelaron y la
Embajada de Estados Unidos alerta a sus
ciudadanos a mantenerse informados y
evitar zonas que en las que pudieran
estar en peligro y recuerda que el
Estado de Sinaloa tiene una alerta de
viaje precisamente por el peligro que se
corre
el presidente de Estados Unidos Joe
biden visitará el próximo domingo por
primera vez la frontera con México para
conocer de primera mano Cuál es la
situación migratoria en la zona Asimismo
el presidente estadounidense arribará a
la Ciudad de México el lunes 9 de enero
para sostener un encuentro con su
homólogo mexicano Andrés Manuel López
Obrador para tratar temas bilaterales de
igual forma se espera que el día
miércoles arrive también a la capital
mexicana El Primer Ministro de Canadá
Justin judo para participar en una
cumbre de países norteamericanos para
tratar temas de competitividad seguridad
cambio climático migración diversidad y
medio ambiente
y ante unos 50.000 personas fue llevada
a cabo el servicio religioso para
despedir al Papa emérito Benedicto 16
cuyo cuerpo ya reposa en las grutas de
la ciudad del Vaticano
Benedicto 16 yace debajo de la Basílica
de San Pedro tal como era su deseo el
papa emérito fue sepultado en las
antiguas criptas donde permaneció Juan
Pablo II el ex líder de la Iglesia
Católica recibió una última despedida
celebrada por el Papa Francisco con
miguetones hemos venido con la fragancia
de la gratitud y el bálsamo o la
esperanza para mostrarle una vez más el
amor que es eterno queremos hacerlo con
la misma sabiduría ternura y devoción
que él nos derramó a lo largo de los
años juntos queremos decir padre en tus
manos encomendamos su espíritu
la jornada contó con la presencia del
canciller alemán olafones entre la
delegación alemana
además en la plaza de San Pedro decenas
de miles de dolientes se congregaron
para el último adiós
Fue una ceremonia hermosa no conocí
personalmente al papa pero he leído algo
escrito por él en el pasado
una ceremonia histórica eso es lo que
voy a recordar era importante para mí
estar aquí decir okay Estuve allí
participé no es una ceremonia que se ve
todos los días el aspecto extremadamente
raro de ver un Papa enterrando a otro Es
realmente un evento único en la historia
alrededor de 200.000 personas estuvieron
en los cinco días de exequias de
Benedicto 16 también más de 4.500
miembros de la Iglesia Católica y
delegaciones de más de 20 países
formaron parte del cierre de una era
histórica en el Vaticano la era de los
dos papas
esto en las noticias aquí en France 24
siga con nosotros buenas tardes
[Música]